The pre-closed screencast guys this is a highly highly effective tool this is
something that should not be skipped this is something that really needs to
be done properly okay so before we top over to the screen I give you guys the
template I want you guys to understand the objective of the pre-closed
screencast which is part of the bigger picture of the setup which is part of
the bigger picture of closing the deal okay the purpose and the objective of
the pre-closed screencast is twofold number one is to overcome objections
that you haven't covered yet okay and there are certain objections that
we covered that we talked about that just fit really nicely inside of the
screencast because it might be weird to bring them up during a phone call okay
so number one is to bring up and overcome objections number two is this
is an opportunity for you to basically pitch them without being interrupted and
without having the pressure of them being on the call like it's really
really nice because you can give this amazing pitch without them even
interrupting you or without feeling like it's a pitch okay and so that those are
the two objectives during this but this is something that I used to not do and I
started implementing this about a year ago maybe it's even less not maybe eight
months ago and it is what it works like a charm because it really gets them
prepped for the call and you guys will probably if you remember back to when
you joined this program okay you probably received a video and you should
have received a video right before it said watch this video before we talk and
during that I overcame a couple of last a couple last objections where I said
hey if you need to talk to your mom or your dog or your goldfish or your aunt
bring them to the call because we're not doing the whole I want to think about
it thing okay and I was overcoming that objection and I and I showed social
proof and I did a few things that's the equivalent of my pre-closed screencast
that I'm gonna teach you here so let's hop over the screen so here we have the
pre-closed screencast template and I want to share with you the structure okay
so there's a couple things that you need to include you don't have to do it in
this specific order this is the order that I do it in and I just want to
explain it this way so the first thing is we want to make sure and by the way
I'm gonna give you guys examples of this we're gonna have some some examples
attached some examples there's tons of examples already in the group of actual
screencasts that I've done so I'm not gonna share one in this video because I
don't want to make it long I just want to share the template okay so the first
thing is I want to share how we get our leads in the strategy behind it and the
thing that I use here is I show them an actual example and I like to use the
monopoly strategy slash concept so I explain the monopoly thing I say hey
look when you're playing monopoly there's a giant board and the more
properties that you can you know buy the better chance you have a win in the game
and these properties at the top or the boardwalk the park place etc etc etc
that's how I explain it and I explain how we get the leads guys I've been in
groups where people ask they're like hey what happens at the business owner they
ask what the website is if they ask what happens if they ask I'm getting the
lead tell them okay guys you don't need to hide stuff this is a very straight-up
process you do not need to hide anything so number one thing is I explain how we
get the leads in the strategy behind again there's gonna be an example I
show you this entire thing okay the second thing as I've listed here is I
show example sites so I like to best case scenario is you show them a niche
sorry you show them a site in the niche that you're going after so if you're
targeting somebody that's doing concrete you show them an example of concrete
you show them a site you show them results you use that as a case study
however if you don't have one this is your first time going into that niche
what I would do and what I typically like to do is I like to show them a case
study an example or a site in that city or close to that city so here in st.
George let's say I have a duck cleaning site but I'm going after tree service I
might not have any other tree services my first tree service site but I'm gonna
show them a duck cleaning site because it just relates they're like oh that
guy's in st. George that lady's in st. George that makes sense right we're
showing these examples so I put that right here preferably in their niche or
in their state and city and then if you guys have a lot of leads coming from
those projects let's say you have a site already built it's generating leads you
can show that if you don't don't worry it's there's not specific things you
need to show you it's just showing them that you've done this before if you have
a really good case study and you can show them hey this business owner has
gotten this many leads show them that okay I noted here if you don't have any
projects you don't have any other sites leverage the group man leverage the
group we have so many case studies combined between all of us in this
program at the time of recording this it's so many case studies so many
websites leverage the group so if you don't have any don't worry about it make
a post search for post and say hey guys does anyone have a concrete project I
can use as a case study use and leverage the group okay number three is I show
social proof okay including screenshots of text messages reviews etc also
sometimes show contracts whatever stripe accounts the proof number one I have
customers number two that people are really making some some money so what I
would recommend is anytime you're communicating with a business owner and
they tell you about some amazing story that they closed a huge monster deal
we've all been on the phone or you will be on the phone where the business owner
says hey you sent me those leads I just closed a $50,000 job what I say in those
situations I'm like hey just so I can use that as kind of a testimony I'm
gonna message you here in just a second after we help with the phone I'm gonna
ask you a question about how things are going if you would just respond don't be
fake about it but if you would just respond and tell me you just what you
just told me on text I can screenshot that and use that as a case study and I
can use that as proof that this works if you wouldn't mind that would help me out
immensely and guys I just have a folder of case studies so for example one of
the ones I use you're gonna see this in the example is I had this lady in Las
Vegas and she sends me a text she's like hey I just closed one of your leads for
like 40 grand so I like to show that example I'm like hey here's one of my
artificial turf clients in Las Vegas she closed the job for 40,000 bucks okay
it's literally proving like hey I showed you the lead value calculator but here
is proof that they're actually that these people are actually closing jobs
okay so I like to show social proof including screenshots screenshots of
text messages reviews etc and then I also like to explain this is where I'm
gonna explain the deal structure so I will basically shit on commission I'm
like hey just you guys know or just so you know here's how the deal typically
works and how we do this first of all we don't and that's how I say first of all
we don't do commission okay there's no skin in the game for you and there's no
incentive for me to even send you leads because I don't even know if you're
gonna close I don't do commission never have never will okay secondly I don't do
paper lead and in the beginning just so you guys understand or just so you
understand mr. business owner mr. business owner I did this in the
beginning and I tell a story I say I used to work with this company and I
sent them leads and we agreed a hundred bucks a lead okay here's what happened
is I they were cool paying at you know I usually shoot high so I get kind of
start price anchoring them I said they were they were cool at a hundred bucks a
lead sending them 20 30 leads paying two three bucks two three grand a month but
my whole goal the whole time was how do I jack these leads how do I get to 50 60
70 because I wanted to make more money obviously I'm human right and let me
tell you what happened once I got and I had that month where the website ranked
and the leads got spiked through the air and I sent them 70 leads and invoice for
seven grand you know what happened they pulled out the red pencil and all of a
sudden it became hey that lead didn't answer hey that lead was it was too far
out hey that lead was a small job and it became this this whole nitpicky thing
okay and it really strained the relationship so since that time that's
been a while that's been two years ago three years ago I have done something
that's been way better and it's called a flat fee deal and so mr. business or
what that means is it's a flat fee deal you pay a certain amount every month or
every week and you get every single lead from this website what does that mean
well sometimes during the winter it's gonna be slow I'm gonna tell you that
right now okay guess what in the spring when the leads are just crushing it and
it's tax return time and people are cleaning up their yards and blah blah
blah I'm not gonna come out to you for more money okay so you know exactly how
much is coming out every single month and you get the upside of those
additional leads okay that's it guys those are the things that I include in
my screencast I noted here do not give price do not give price I usually let
them know after I explain the deal structure I'm like hey as far as the
actual cost per month or per week we're gonna discuss that tomorrow I got to
finish writing the numbers but I promise you will be reasonable and then I last
thing as I noted here is I like to end with a pullback okay so what I say is
hey so I'm look I'm really looking forward to talking tomorrow and by the
way like all I want to do is see if this is a good fit if we find out this is a
good fit let's make something happen let's make a lot of money together but
at the same time if it's not no big deal you know there's a lot of companies to
work with and I only work with one okay see tomorrow and I just end with that
pullback I'm taking off the pressure I'm letting them know hey no big deal no
harm no foul I end with that pullback guys the pullbacks you can use them
again and again and again and you can never overuse them so guys after you've
done the screencast and just so you know I should have mentioned this earlier the
tool that I like to use is a tool it's called the Vimeo recorder in fact hop
over the screen let me show you what I'm talking about so guys over here on the
Google Chrome store if you guys aren't using Google Chrome you're crazy I've
already mentioned this you need to be go to the just type in Google Chrome store
and you can get this little plug-in or this little extension I apologize just
type in Vimeo and it's this Vimeo record I love this one because you can just
push up here you could probably see it right here you could just push this and
like if I click it like this it's literally just gonna let me push start
recording and I'm automatically there and then as soon as I'm done it's just
gonna upload it to my Vimeo account okay so I really really like that tool but
there's a ton of tools that you can use so make sure that you record the tool as
a screencast that's number one number two when you send this screencast make
sure that you can track it so you know there's like if you want to use loom
that's cool too loom is gonna tell you when they open the screencast that's a
cool tool I like having Vimeo because I use Vimeo for everything loom would be a
cool tool because you can see it so what I typically do is I use a software where
if I send this as an email I send a link as an email I can tell when they
open the email and when they clicked on the link and there's a ton of tools I
don't even want to mention any but I used to use one called banana tag which
they've since kind of gone out of business I don't even know if my banana
tag even works anymore and so I don't even have to ask myself guys what we're
using at this time but I definitely recommend finding something and you
could just go ahead and Google and type in link let's see like email opening
software whatever and there's gonna be tons of options let me get rid of this
this is really bugging me okay trash this get rid of this okay yeah so write
inbox sales handy mail check whatever just use something so that you know
when they open the link and when they watch the video okay lastly make sure
they watch the video okay if you guys record these videos and then they don't
watch them what why'd you record it right why did you record it make sure
they watch the video so before you jump on the call say hey talk to you in 30
minutes just want to make sure you watch the video before we talk okay that is
going to be part of the the the objections we're overcoming part of the
objections during that video so they have to watch it you guys notice before
we got on a call before you join flat view mastery you were sent a video and
and I said or whoever onboarded you said hey make sure you watch this video
before we talk guys there is no hidden secret here I am doing the exact same
process that I'm teaching right here and it's working like a charm and the last
thing I want to mention is the length of these videos should be no more than 10
minutes 10 to 12 max but guys if you start rambling on you start talking
about stupid stuff that no one cares about you start talking about backlinks
and you start including stuff that I didn't cover in the template you're
going to lose them they're not gonna watch the video okay get to the point be
conversational talk to them like you're talking to them in person and make this
something that they can actually stand listening to do not get into backlinks
and the ranking and all this crazy stuff and do not make this 15 minutes okay 10
minutes or less the shorter the better the shorter that the shorter it is the
more likely they are to watch the video